is
all right good afternoon and welcome to
today's Richard M carp distinguished
lecture I'm Sandy Irani the associate
director of the assignments Institute
so the Institute is uh for those of you
who are unfamiliar is the leading
international venue for collaborative
research and theoretical computer
science we were started with a generous
Grant from the Simon's foundation in
2012. and we established this Richard M
carp distinguished lecture series to
celebrate the role of founding director
dick karp in theoretical computer
science formulating its Central problems
and an amazing array of results
um and it features uh Talks by Visionary
leaders in the field and it's geared
towards a broad scientific audience and
we're really grateful to the many people
who have contributed to make this fund
this distinguished lecture series
possible and today I'm really happy to
welcome our speaker Monica hensiger
I met Monica when she was a graduate
student in Princeton and I was spending
my part of my postdoc here there
um that was just a few years ago five
five or ten years ago
um she was already a rising star in the
field of dynamic graph algorithms and
has been a Pioneer in that area ever
since
and since that time she's spent almost a
decade as a director of research at
Google
and then she's had professorships at efl
in Switzerland the University of Vienna
and now the Institute of Science and
Technology in Austria
she's very well decorated for her many
contributions to the field member of the
Austrian Academy of Science she's
received two prestigious Advance grants
from the European research Council and
in 2021 she was awarded the Wittgenstein
prize the highest scientific award in
Austria so I'm really excited to welcome
Monica today and she's going to tell us
about Dynamic graph algorithms what we
know and what we don't know so
[Applause]
thank you so much thank you for this
great introduction and thank you for not
telling any embarrassing stories about
me as grad student
I was worried there for a second
okay so you see I work at this beautiful
place you see a picture here of ISC
Austin and of course they should all
come and visit or apply for a poster
position it's wonderful there
okay so but today I will actually tell
you about Dynamic graph algorithms now
it turns out while they are
theoretically interesting and that's
what you heard last in last week's carp
lecture
um they're also practical and useful for
real life so in the real life they're
all the time large changing graphs for
example you look at Street networks
right there are traffic jams coming and
going and you always want to know the
shortest path
um there's social networks that continue
to grow that's what this is Ohio wrong
pointer this little thing here is
supposed to show they continue to grow
so nodes keep on being added and you
might want to know clusters in their
craft same thing with the World by web
you might want to analyze that many
physical systems are actually modeled as
networks dynamically changing networks
they've also a study conducted in 2020
amongst computer scientists that work in
the field in the industry and also more
than half of them worked on large
dynamically changing graphs
okay so in this talk I will first give
you a very brief introduction to what
are Dynamic graph algorithms in case you
don't know then I'll show you the state
of the art and then I'll talk a little
bit about what's going on right now for
lower bounds and I also show you one
upper balance technique and finally I
talk about the experimental evaluation
for dynamic graph algorithms because I
think that's also important and
mentioning future work all through the
talk and also at the end
okay so assume you have some
computational problem and the static
setting is a usual one you have some
input you stick it in the algorithm you
get some output and you're interested in
the running time and if you can solve
the problem exactly in the approximation
ratio
now however assume you did this one so
you had some input you start in the
algorithm got some output and now the
input slightly changes there's a traffic
jam here happening right now okay so
some small change and now you want to
get a new output
and you'd like to get this new output
faster than recomputing from scratch
you'd like to take advantage of the fact
that you saw it already for this similar
output for the similar input
and then you might get another small
change and so on and so forth so the
question that we are studying is can we
if there are just small changes to the
input can we compute the output faster
than recomputing every time from scratch
and if you have formulated this way it's
really a data structures problem okay so
whenever we talk about Dynamic
algorithms or dynamic graph algorithms
it's completely wrong we should always
talk about Dynamic data structures and
dynamic graph data structures however
the field causes Dynamic graph
algorithms and so we live with this name
but in reality it's a data structure
what we want okay we want to store a
graph and then we want to provide
operations to modify the graph to update
or to ask queries
okay to access the data
okay and so really what we want is we
want to have some initialization and
then we want to have queries and we want
to have some more updates and we have
queries and so on and so forth if we
always put this into the data structure
and get some output and the question is
how fast can we do the updates in the
queries
so in this talk specifically I talk
about Dynamic graph algorithms and so
what you get is input is a graph and you
have one operation that's initialization
you only execute that once and it's
running time is called the
pre-processing time
and then you have a sequence of updates
so you might insert edges or delete
edges and you could also insert or
delete nodes and often we don't study
this because we assume that there is an
infinite set or as many as you need
isolated notes sitting around anyway and
so you can always model inserting a node
or deleting a node by just taking an
isolated node and adding edges or
removing edges of an existing node
okay and these are the updates and then
you can ask queries queries might have
no parameter or one or two or whatever
you want
okay
now note that there are also other
Dynamic models that I'm not talking
about in this talk but I want to also
acknowledge them and they also have
interesting work
so there's the insertions only setting
called the incremental setting the
deletions only setting decremental
setting so I'm going to talk about fully
Dynamic the fully Dynamic setting that
you can do insertions and deletions but
there are also these two settings and
there's tons of works also in this area
mostly because there are problems for
which we know or we think we know that
you cannot solve them efficiently in the
fully Dynamic setting and then we are
still trying to get efficient algorithms
at least in the incremental or
decremental setting
there is however also the subgraph model
um where you give them an initial graph
and then an update can just turn on or
off individual nodes
and when you ask a query it's always a
query in the graph induced by the nodes
that are currently turned on
which was a very good model the other
one is the if sensitivity model or also
called emergency model
where you give more than initial graph
and then you do a batch update of size F
which means you're doing F update
operations all at once
and then you ask the query in this
modify graph
and then you go back to the original
graph
okay and now you can do the next batch
and the question is always how quickly
can you do a patch and this is also
called the emergency setting because it
was motivated by by this uh setting that
assume you have a city and there are all
these Bridges around it and then you say
what if these Bridges go down can I
still get my population out or what if
these bridges are down how quickly can I
get my populations out okay that's where
the motivation came from but also an
interesting model
a little bit further away are this
kinetic data structures so they're more
geometric so here the nodes are points
in space and you're given a trajectory
for every node
and you might be interested in which
nodes are close to which other nodes and
the update operation is changing the
trajectory
um then there are the either streams
you're probably familiar with that
um here you have always a sequence of
updates and usually you just ask one
question at the end
one query that should say another update
and here you care mostly about the space
not so much about the running time but
the space is the most important thing
and finally more recently temporary
graphs have become popular
um not sure who invented them but I know
of some early work by campaign tardash
in that field and in the last five to
ten years people have more and more
started to work on them so here the idea
is that you give them a graph and every
Edge has labels that indicate when the
edge exists so think of a Time Dimension
so every Edge has a label that says it
exists from this time to that time and
then again from this end to that time
and now traversing an edge takes you one
time step
and now you want to might want to ask
can I get from A to B or how quickly can
I get from A to B and if you travel from
A to B and you add some node V you can
actually automate at this node until an
edge becomes available to leave the note
again
so these are temporary graphs that they
study different questions than we do
so back to Dynamic graph algorithms I
already talked about the real world
applications last week in Aaron's talk
you heard about the fact that they can
be used very successfully as
subproutines and study graph algorithms
and I just wanted to convince you that
it's just also a very fundamental
computational question that we are
asking how quickly can information be
updated after small changes
so these are the motivations for
studying these questions
now what's known I will work on this
started in roughly in the 90s or even
the 80s and so not surprisingly there's
lots known already the performance
measures that are used are usually the
pre-processing time what we want usually
is either linear or small polynomial
processing time
and then we look at the time per
operation
and is reviewed in such a Poor's
excellent uh talks during the or you
might have heard during the boot camp
there are different kinds of models how
the input is generated we call them
adversary the process that generates the
input so there are different kinds of
inputs for adversaries they are adaptive
adversaries oblivious adversaries were
also offline Dynamic adversaries the
offline Dynamic so in the Adaptive you
have an adversary that knows the output
of everything so far before deciding on
the new update operation or the new
query operation
oblivious setting the adversary first
has to generate all the operations
and fix them and then the algorithm
starts running the algorithm doesn't
know the operations but the adversary
has to write them down so the adversary
cannot adapt the operations towards the
output of previous operations
okay they are fixed so the adversary is
oblivious to the output of other
operations
and in the offline Dynamic model
the adversary is even weaker so the
adversary produces a sequence of
operations and then they are given to
the algorithm and the algorithm can look
at them and only after seeing all of
them does the algorithm have to produce
their outputs in the order
and so here you're taking basically the
online component completely out of it
and the question is just how hard is it
to get the sequence of answers
and it's mostly interesting for lower
bounds because we can show many lower
bounds or also in an offline Dynamic
model
there's a usual thing in data structures
amortized versus worst case running time
will not get much into that in this talk
and then there's usually a trade-off
between query and update time because
you might not do anything during an
update except for writing down what
happened and then do all the work at
query time
well alternatively you could do all the
work at update time answer all possible
queries pre-compute the answers and then
a query time you only have to look up
the answer
what we want usually is that queries are
answered in poly lock time because the
idea is you want to get answers quickly
and then under these constraints you
want to have the updates as fast as
possible
now this might not always be possible
because maybe the output is larger the
importantly logarithmic assume you want
to actually output the shortest path and
it happens to be a very long path
in that case what we do is either we say
okay you should be output sensitive
meaning the running time should be
proportional to the size of the output
well we only return the value of the
solution which might be a little bit of
a cheat we just give you the value of
the shortest path and not the shortest
path itself
we just give you the change in the
solution yeah for example for minimum
payment tree that works very well we
don't always give you the you know
spanning tree we just tell you how much
which edges have left the Minimus
benefits in which edges have gone into
the minimum spend increase three after
one update
okay so the hope is that there are not
many changes to the solution and thus
this can be done quickly
okay and then of course we look at the
approximation ratio just as in the
static setting
okay now how do you see it I will now
show you lists of what's known without
coming much into details and then I'll
go into some more details so the
notation is that I use as a usual one N
is a number of nodes m is the number of
edges in the graph and poly logarithmic
always means poly logarithmic in n and I
use the O tilde notation to mean that
I'm hiding poly log factors
no o heads here
okay so here is the outline of the talk
I give you now the state of the art in
Dynamic graph algorithms so you're
prepared for long lists okay so because
this has been a field that has been
working for quite a while we know a lot
and so uh in with regard to Upper bounds
but still there are some annoying holes
okay so for undirected graph
when I use Epsilon here I mean always
any small Epsilon larger than zero
so for undirected graphs there's a lower
bound of login and there is an upper
bound of also poly login I think it's
now login times anyway small small poly
log and while Lori and I gave the first
randomized algorithm for this holding
deletion thought up against the first
deterministic time algorithm for this in
general I make the results here in bold
whenever they work against an Adaptive
adversary because that's the strongest
adversary
um minimum spending tree same situation
uh Edge connectivity same lower bound
and there has been some reason progress
in the upper bound
a single Source shoulders path exact
this is lower bound and this upper bound
so they're just some small factors apart
so basically close
but for all pair Shores paths
interesting things happen already
there's this very old and classic
algorithm by dimitresco Italiano which
is basically N squared but the lower
bound is just basically linear in the
number of edges so for sparse graphs
there is still a gap
St maxflow um basically closed maximum
cardinality matching has again an
interesting uh Gap namely lower bound of
basically square root M upper bound of M
this is for exact if you do approximate
you have also an upper bound of in in
bicarbonate in general graphs Channel
graphs yeah bypasses nothing better no
yeah
um if you have one minus Epsilon
approximate matching maximum Cardinal
Dimension you have a square of them
um another interesting Gap is of course
here with Edge connectivity the only
lower bound we have is this login and
these are the upper bounds so there's
another interesting Gap here
okay director graphs
um reachability basically tight strongly
connected component
um we only have this lower bound of
square root M and then the trivial upper
bound of M there has been some
interesting work here if you allow
higher query time okay but I don't want
to go into that
um transitive closure again interesting
Gap and this is work if you allow High
query time and then open shoulders path
again the same Gap but in the undirected
case so you see we know a lot of things
but there are some still classic
problems where we still have gaps
now if you allow for approximation you
get even more work okay so hold your
breath this first result you will hear
about a talk
next week okay you will get this in the
workshop this will be presented and
tons of other work
um points of other work I will actually
talk a little bit today about this upper
part because I think it's elegant and
also I think there's some more work that
one should be doing
um and next week also this one here uh
Cheyenne will talk about this one here
in the workshop
in general I actually wrote a survey
together
with Catherine Hanover and Christian
troops on uh both theoretically as well
as experimental work on Dynamic graph
algorithms you can find it on the
archive and also yeah in the journal
now let me go to lower bounds and now
I'm gonna get a bit more technical
so in lower bounds I have to just
quickly review the OMB conjecture
because my work is going to build on top
of this and the omv conjecture is as
follows and assume you're given a
Boolean n by n Matrix
and you also have a sequence of n n
dimensional vectors Boolean vectors
arriving
now what you want to do is always to a
Boolean multiplication of this Vector
with a matrix
and the trick is that you have to Output
the answer of the first Vector
multiplied with the Matrix before you
get the second vector
okay so you have to always as soon as
you get a vector you have to Output the
answer Boolean multiplication
in the conjecture is that there is no
algorithm with total time
um o of n to the three minus Epsilon for
any Epsilon larger than zero
okay for these n vectors arriving
it turns out based on this lower bound
there are now tons of lower bounds for
all kind of problems and also before the
lower bounds that I showed you that were
not log in they were actually always a
conditional lower bounds either
conditional on the OMB conjecture or
conditional on other conjectures
okay while the lower bound that was log
n there was actually cell probe okay so
we'll get to this what about
unconditional lower bounds well the only
unconditional lower bounds are in the
sale prop model it's an excellent model
and
um yeah the best we knew until very very
recently is this lower bound of log n by
patrascon domain it works for dynamic
connectivity to Edge connectivity
planarity testing things like that
but now I can tell you about the first
Super logarithmic bound which was
actually achieved by Green Larsen and
you can't read it here and you have it
on my last slide it just was put on
archive in April 23. and and what it
shows is that for insertions only
reachability and acyclic graph
if the worst case update time is poly
logarithmic then the expected query time
must be logged into the three halves
divided by lower clock n
okay so you cannot have that both are
better than log into the three half
so this is very exciting because there
was only some very unnatural graph
problem for which we had a super
logarithmic lower bound and now we have
a super logarithmic lower Bound for this
reachability problem
however if you look at it in the
conditional lower bounds for fully
Dynamic ritability we have a m to the 1
minus Epsilon lower bound so
sorry yes this is in the Cell Pro Model
this here this new work yeah by this
year conditional of course not yeah
so um so the conclusion is that um oh
sorry too far the conclusion is that um
there's still many problems or things
that we do not know about right so if
you are happy with our conjecture then
you think all these problems are solved
but if you insist on having a cell prop
lower bound then we are still far from
solving these problems because the best
lower bounds are still just poly
logarithmic
moreover you might also ask something
else
you might ask are these worst case
sequences overly pessimistic right all
these things here are all these lower
bonds are built on this it supposedly
conjecture one worst case sequence isn't
this overly pessimistic
and so what I recently looked at was
Lincoln and Saha is we looked at the
so-called average Case Model
the average Case Model is built on the
notion of edge flips instead of doing
intuitions or delicious we think of edge
flips and H flip is as follows if you
give me UV if the edge exists then
delete it
if it does not exist then insert it
so basically it's like flipping the bit
for this Edge whether it exists or not
and now we propose a very weak adversary
which we call average case adversary and
this adversary can only control whether
the next operation is a flip it's an
update or a query but it cannot control
which Edge gets flipped
okay if the adversary says update then a
random Edge will be flipped
and this is of course motivated by the
education graphs and indeed if you start
out with an address Randy graph and you
only do this kind of update operations
you will always have an error training
graph
these are going to be dense mostly
um it depends on what your initial graph
was yeah yes but the adversary cannot
control the density because the
adversary can only say update and not
say insert or something like this can
only say update yeah
so now the question is which problems
are hard and which are easy in this
model
okay and so what we found out is we were
looking at counting model problems in
dynamic graphs and it turned out there's
a bunch of problems that are easy
meaning we can do expect a constant time
in the average Case Model even so in our
worst case models or the standard OMB
bottle that they call that worst case
don't think your worst case versus
amortized I just say worst case when I
mean the standard so even so in the
standard OMB model we actually had an
almost linear lower bound
these problems are counting the number
of triangles that go through a fixed
node s or if you give me a fixed s and t
counting the number of Paths of length
three or counting the number of Paths of
links four
we're counting the number of cycles of
lengths four that go through a fixed
node s
this one we can do an amortized constant
time expected
however we were also able to show that
there are some problems that are equally
hard so that have a lower bound almost
linear lower Bound in both models
and this was more surprising for us
um so it's for example counting the
number of triangles they go through a
random query node so the adversary can
just say query and then a random node
gets picked and then the algorithm needs
to return the number of triangles that
go through this chosen node
what counting to fix some s and t
counting the number of Paths of length
five
and this seems very surprising because
actually counting the number of Paths of
links four we can do still in expect a
constant time
but counting the number of Paths of
length five we have this lower Bond
also counting the number of four Cycles
and now this upper bound here
are usually achieved
as follows we keep two types of data
structures
there is one type of data structure that
needs to be very fast and every time
when the adversary says query or update
this data structure might have to be
updated
but then there's also some other data
structures that can be slow
and the idea is that
it will happen infrequently that these
data structures need to be updated
so for example if you think of counting
the number of s triangles
and if you insert an edge that's not
incident to s
you will only run the fast data
structure and that has to run in
constant time
but if you insert an edge incident to S
which will only happen with probability
one over n
then you can run a slow data structure
okay so the trick is always
these problems are chosen in such a way
that there are some updates that will
happen that are unlikely to happen and
thus we can have a slow data structure
for them and for the others uh you need
to be fast for the other updates
I just want it the clarification on the
model
the initial graph is its worst case or
or is what
um the initial graph is the other
training graph oh yes
yes some probability
yes yes
I mean if you changed it to be
a worst case graph but required a long a
lot this would still work here this
would still work if you allow me linear
pre-processing yeah yes of course I need
to do process yeah
yes
I was so fast and like the worst case
model but you're forced to like even
worse every vertex the software
not to belong to many like
like French vertex
um
so the question is is this model still
hard it's for every node uh it can only
have a constant number of incident edges
to be updated
um
we did not look at that more that
variant and
um
maybe maybe I would have to go through
the proofs and see whether they still go
through whether we use somewhere the
fact that every Edge can exist
yeah good question I don't know
any other questions
okay
so now let me just briefly uh
uh ask a question what is the status of
non-counting problem I'm only talking
about non-county problems well the only
other paper I'm aware of is some paper
by here Fried Chicken having house which
shows that this oil pair showed us
Dynamic oil past shortest path data
structure which takes n Square Time by
dimitrisco Italiano that in this model
here
would only take n to the 4 over 3 and
under certain conditions even better
other than this there are no algorithms
no no fast algorithms no in this model
okay now let me tell you a little bit
about this lower bounds because that's
more surprising right that there's these
lower bounds and how we do this lower
bounds
so the basic ideas we start out again
with the worst case OMB contractor
and we first show remember in OMB it's
always Boolean multiplications and first
we show how to change this into parity
operations so still it's a Boolean
Matrix zero and one but the operations
you do is basically some model of two
okay
so we do Parry the omv hardness and once
we have uh hardness of Caribbean V we
show hardness average case hardness so
hardness in this average Case Model of
parity omv
and the ideas as follows
um assume you're given the m and the
vivanta v n from the parity omv hardness
proof now what you do is you pick a
random Matrix R and pick random vectors
V1 to V in
and now instead of solving M times V1
and so on
you're solving these four problems so
when for each eye what you do is you
solve the random Matrix X over it with m
and then you do a parity multiplication
with vixor with RI
okay that's one of them and then the
others are this here here is just with
RI it's just r with VI x r i and r with
RI
so all of these things here look like
random matrices and random vectors
because we export them with random ones
they're highly correlated but each one
individually looks random and of course
they're chosen in such a way that if
your X or the answer of the four you get
the correct answer
okay so this was done before in the
static setting and we're doing it now in
the dynamic setting basically if you're
hiding a worst case instance
um in four random bonds
okay
now this sounds nice and easy but
actually making it work on graphs it's a
pain and the paper is rather long
because we have to deal with all these
details so one detail is for example
that in the standard OMB reduction a
vector is usually represented by water
and many edges in the graph
by The Matrix is represented by N
squared edges sorry Theta in HS well m
is represented by Theta N squared edges
in the graph the graph that you do to
reduce OMB to some graph problem
and now
um
now the adversary is allowed to just say
flip so we need to you have one vector
and you now need to create the second
Vector okay so assume you had just
change the graph to represent the first
Vector we want and now the second Vector
arrives and now you need to change the
graph to represent the second vector
in order to flip one bit in this of the
vector v let's say V2 you had V1 now V2
to flip one bit which means you need to
flip the corresponding Edge in the graph
well if they're just NHS Theta NH is
representing the vertex but all together
they are representing this one vector so
there's one h a constant number of edges
representing a certain bit
and now out of N squared edges you need
to hit exactly this one here
the probability that you hit the right
one will be way too small right
um but if you say you want to hit all
there are these NHS you need to update
them what's the probability that a
random flip will actually update one of
these edges there are n good edges and
all together they are n plus N squared
H's so the proper the probability is
just roughly one over n
and so this is a problem because if you
need to flip all the random uh older
bits in an edge it will not all the bits
in the vector it will not cost you N
squared many operations to flip all bits
to flip one bit the probability is just
one over n so you expect to have to do n
flips to flip one Edge correspondingly
and you need to flip all n edges in the
vector so it would cost you N squared
many random flips
and then this reduction if you do N
squared work to a model to simulate one
multiplication your date you get no
lower bound anymore so this will be too
many operations
so what we do instead is we're
representing each vector by Theta N
squared many edges
now however while doing flips for edges
to represent vectors you might
accidentally also flip bits that are in
The Matrix
right so bits in The Matrix can also be
flipped and now you don't have the
Matrix anymore that you want it yeah you
have some additional Randomness in there
that you didn't want
so in order to deal with this we need to
do a similar trick as before we need to
actually create three randomly looking
problems and then the X all of them will
always X or out the the accidentally
created random flips
okay there are more technicalities in
there but I will not bore you with them
just telling you it's actually a pain to
make this simple idea of work to get
this lower bound through
but now what's the implication
so first of all we get a finer
classification of the heart problems in
the standard model okay what used to be
hard some of them are easy in the
average case so maybe they are the
standard model was too pessimistic
and the others are still hard in the
average case
so and as soon as your heart in the
average case on random sequences it
means that it's hard on many input
sequences
but this last thing also has a further
implication and so think of algorithms
with predictions if a problem is hard
for random input instances there cannot
be any useful prediction
right because you cannot predict the
random sequence
so the idea is that since random
sequences cannot be predicted if a
problem is hard in the average case
it will also imply hardness for
algorithms with predictions for this
problem
and this gave us then the idea to work
on algorithms with predictions more
generally to work on Lower bounds for
algorithms with predictions
and this is very recent work we saw her
Sable and here and uh will be here next
week for the workshop and the model is
as follows during the pre-processing
step the algorithm is given the
prediction sequence so it's sort of like
the offline Dynamic model where the
algorithm is given the whole sequence of
updates and requests
now we're away from the average Case
Model okay we're back to the worst case
model and the algorithm is given the
sequence of updates initially except it
might be a bit wrong
you have this is just the predicted
upgrade sequence and it might be a bit
wrong and now there are different ways
of saying what does it mean to be a bit
wrong we looked at three different ones
one is data accurate predictions this
comes mostly from the static algorithms
with prediction model that also you
could look at Delta correct predictions
also comes from machine learning where
you can say you know with a certain
probability what you predict will be
correct
um so here in each step each operation
is predicted correctly with some
probability data
and in the llist accurate prediction for
each time step you give them a set of L
menu operations and you say it will be
one of them and the correct one needs to
be in there
and in the Delta bounded delay
predictions
and the sequence of the predicted
sequence of operations is completely
correct except that the timing might be
a bit off
each operation might be up to d off from
the correct time
okay so it's a bit too late a bit too
early
now here what we can show is actually if
the omv reductions fulfill certain
conditions which all our
graph reductions too
then you can show a strong lower bounds
so then now close to linear time
prediction algorithm exists for a data
accurate predictions if data is less
than one or for two list accurate
predictions or for
Omega n boundary delay prediction so if
things can be up to n positions wrong
okay so we can show that these
predictions will not help the problems
are just as hard as before
and so the corollary that we have is all
Dynamic graph algorithms with OMB based
lower bounds cannot have close to linear
algorithms of these types this is not
really formula but you know in our paper
we have all this list of problems for
which this goes through
okay this also makes sense there were
two recent papers that actually started
upper bounds and one of them by funder
brand
Foster
authors worked on oil past shortest path
and they looked and let algorithms
responded delay predictions and indeed
they again just dealt with the
insertions only in the deletions only
model and not the fully dynamic they had
improved results for them and this now
explains why because basically the lower
bounds go through
and the delays on me the delay is like
big enough yes if it's picking up yes
that's huge right that's like Beauty
where all event is is not the length no
the length of the segment is N squared
okay yeah the number of update
operations
good point
and so to summarize the lower bounds
um
perform lower bounds are the gold
standards but so far we only have poly
logarithmic lower bounds
um conditional lower bounds there we
have many uh polynomial lower bounds and
somehow do you mean the average Case
Model
and for algorithms with predictions for
these three prediction models that we
looked at uh you get many of the lower
bounds carryover
okay so now
let me go to Upper bounds
specifically I want to tell you about
one specific algorithm uh namely Dynamic
probabilistic tree embeddings that I
worked on with uh goransi and Foster and
I'm telling you that because first of
all I think it's kind of cute but second
of all I also think it deserves more
work so I want to bring it to the
attention of this very smart audience
and uh yeah maybe some of you manage to
get some improvements
okay so here's the topic it's about tree
based graph approximations so the
general observation is many algorithms
are easy on trees than on channel graphs
and thus the goal is if you're given
some algorithmic problem and some graph
G you want to represent G by a tree in
such a way that all the original nodes
are also nodes in the tree but there can
be additional notes in the tree
um the edges of the tree can have
weights and the solution of the property
of the problem on T can be quickly
converted into a good solution of p on
the graph so it tells you something
about your graph
and this is called an embedding of g
into t
okay so for example if this was the
graph this could be the corresponding
tree so all the nodes in the graph would
be here for example leaves in the tree
and it could be this is one that gets
mapped here and this is two gets left
here for example
and then there are the Blue Notes here
are additional artificial nodes
now there are three base graph
approximations already for all kind of
problems so for example if you just want
to know connectivity then a spanning
forest would be a tree base graph
approximation yeah it has the same nodes
as the original one and it said it has
exactly the same connectivity properties
if you go to expected pairwise distances
for each node where I'll cut the others
yeah but if you go to expected pairwise
distances for each node pair then what
you need or what you use is a
probabilistic tree embedding and I will
explain what this is in the next few
slides
so we will assume obviously the gravity
is connected and then the distance of u
and v and G is the length of the
shortest path
it now the stretch of G and T and UV
will be the length of u and v and T
divided by the length of u and v in G
the distance of them in G the embeddings
will always be so that the distance will
not go down so if you only have a
certain distance in G the in the
embedded graph T in the 3T their
distance will either be the same or
higher
okay and then you say the stretch of an
embedding so stretch GT is the maximum
stretch of any node pair
okay
now look at the cycle as example
assume this is your graph
and now if you delete one he then you
get the three t e sub e
now what do you notice well no matter
which Edge you delete there will always
be a node pair that used to have stretch
one and now it has stretch n minus one
okay so deterministically there's
nothing you can do
and this was even proven formally
and thus part I'll hit this clever idea
of looking at a distribution over trees
so if gamma is a set of all trees T sub
e
if you choose a random tree uniformly at
random out of this set gamma
and now you look at the stretch the
expected stretch what you get
it's as follows for every Edge X Y in
the graph the expected Edge is the
expected stretch over this distribution
is as follows with probability one over
n you actually pick this Edge and then
now you have stretch n minus 1. but with
probability one minus one over n you did
not pick the edge and then you just have
stretch one
so all together you have stretch at most
two
which is two times the distance in the
graph because the graph was one the
distance in the graph was one
and by induction you can show that this
holds for every node pair
so actually the stretch is at most two
okay the expected stretch is the most
true
okay and so now we Define an alpha
stretch probabilistic tree embedding to
be the following a given a graph g and
an alpha larger equal than one a
distribution over a set gamma of beta
trees so you have to come up with a set
gum of weighted trees is an alpha
stretch probabilistic preembedding if
for each tree
the nodes in the original graph are
subset of the notes in t
and for each pair UV its distance in the
tree is only larger than the distance in
the graph
and the expected stretch of all three t
with this distribution is at most Alpha
and now what we just showed in the
previous slide it's actually a little
Lemma that carp showed in 89 and since
it's a carp lecture I thought I have to
cite this work so in 89 he showed that
there existed two stretch probabilistic
tree embedding for the inside here
okay
now there was more work sequence of work
which ended in this great work which
showed that for every graph there
existed water log and stretch
probabilistic tree embedding and this
bound is tight you cannot hope to get
better
and now notice that an alpha stretch
probabilistic tree embedding returns a
random sample tree it does not give you
the whole set of trees and the
distribution of it okay it would take
too much time what it does is it gives
you so an either strike probabilistic
tree embedding algorithm just to turn
you a tree that's sampled according to
this distribution it will be important
now in the dynamic setting
so it's basically a randomized algorithm
that returns a tree such that the
expected stretch is at most Alpha
okay and so play log View and Sun showed
that there exists and what a log and
stretch probabilistic tree embedding
algorithm with running time M login
okay fast okay basically yeah we will
use it
okay now you can ask okay can I do this
dynamically can I have a dynamic
overstretch probabilistic tree embedding
algorithm this is what I want to tell
you about
there was also some related work they
showed average stretch average stretch
is not a probabilistic to embedding it's
a bit weaker because you don't get a
result for every pair of nodes just in
the average
okay I'm missing something yeah nice
picture so a dynamic probabilistic tree
embedding algorithm is as follows so you
have S before you have your sequence of
graphs they always change by inserting
or deleting one Edge
in this algorithm always outputs a
sequence of trees
such that for each eye the expected
stretch is at most Alpha
and
we show two results
and so here actually the algorithm will
not even explicitly give you the tree if
a Constructor tree internally and if you
want to have it it will give you the
tree it will give you the edges of the
tree but actually giving you the three
will take your time linear in the size
of the sheet
okay and I've been talking about the
first result
and this is the first non-trivial
Dynamic probabilistic tree embedding
algorithm but you know as you can see
you would like to do a little bit better
like it would be nice to have smaller
stretch so statically you can have
stretch it's just login and here we are
log into the four
and
um running time is square of them okay
we get it down to end to the little old
one but then the stretch goes up to end
to the little one
yeah you could do that you could say
give me the labels or you can say give
me the tree then the other two literally
has actually I can give you the whole
tree
but then it takes time linear the size
of the tree
other than this you can say yes for
example uh here is a note give me all
its incident edges in the tree because
the graph the data structure has a
representation of the tree inside so it
can produce it it's just that outputting
it
um you know if the graph is sparse you
only have square them update time so or
say let me say it differently this is
the update time in the community time is
linear if you want the output if you
want to get the tree it takes a linear
time because I have to give you the tree
yes outputting the tree is linear and N
exactly and not in m and you can also
ask questions like here's a note give me
all the edges that are in incident to
this node in the tree in time linear
number yes what does it look like
inside
you only want deletions then we actually
have a better result
if we only have insertion scrambles did
we have a better result
given
um you want to only have the changes in
the chat yeah if you just want the data
yeah then it depends a little bit
because we infrequently we will
recompute our data structure as you will
see in a second and when we recompute
then the tree can completely change
while otherwise uh in between there will
be smaller changes yeah yeah so it
depends on it whether you get lucky or
not basically how lots of changes
yes
so the expectation is it over on one
distribution
and
his expectation over which it is it's
just a randomization of the algorithm
right just like I said before this is a
randomized algorithm which to returns a
tree that in expectation has stretch
approached Alpha initials
no this is the this is the currency so
it should actually be T sub I down here
and maybe that's what you're pointing
out yes it should be T sub I yes thank
you
okay
um
so the algorithm consists out of two
parts the first part is a this deletions
only uh probabilistic tree embedding
algorithm and then we make it fully
dynamic
and the deletions only algorithm and
here we can do log cubed stretch so
that's better and we have new linear
runtime m to the one plus little o of
one so that's not uh too bad and and it
also it gives you a tree back
that has leaves the test steps at most
login and where the nodes of the graph
are exactly the leaves in the tree you
guarantee this by this deletions only
algorithm and we will need this when we
make it fully dynamic
and this algorithm basically follows
particles approach what makes it
decremental okay so that requires new
data structures and some work
um but the basic idea is to use this
boil growing process and build suitable
data structures to make it to make it
work so we're not going to this and if
you want to improve the algorithm I
think you could use this as a black box
and try to make the insertions part
that would be a good first step but you
can of course also go into this so let
me skip that now how do we make it fully
dynamic
so here I'm using a technique that such
a pole had in this talk that he talked
about batch updates and basically this
would be some kind of batch update
techniques
um so what we do is we maintain two data
structures at each point in time we have
a deletions only probabilistic T
embedding algorithm the one from the CRM
and we keep a set I of HS that we
inserted since the last three bit
and then every square root M updates we
will rebuild the deletions only
probabilistic tree embedding data
structure to reflect the current graph
okay so you have the insertions in it
because it's missing the insertions
since the last since the last rebuilt
okay good and so now assuming H is
inserted or deleted and what do you do
if the edge was deleted you update the
deletion status structure if it was
inserted you update the set I edit y
and then in order to build the new tree
and what you do is you look at the
current tree in the probabilities only
probabilistic tree embedding let's say
this one here
and now let I be the endpoints of the
inserted edges so these are the edges in
I that are missing in the graph right so
they are missing also in this
probabilistic tree embedded tree okay so
you're adding them to the tree we're
thinking of adding them in a tree first
you're just drawing this nice picture so
this is a tree for the delicious on a
tree and now we're thinking of of these
edges and now what we do is we build a
following graph P what we do is
for every end point of an inserted Edge
we take the full path to the root
remember it's only depth login so in
this way you only add order login many
nodes per inserted Edge
okay and so the size of this thing here
will be the size of I Times log n so
this is the graph that we really built
and then we compute the probabilistic
tree embedding of this thing
and in order to do this we run the
static algorithm this fast static
algorithm that I told you before this
only has size square of them because I
Times log n because I only as I Square
them so I can do this very quickly so I
get this thing here
and now notice that there were some
parts of this original thing
original Three TD that I did not keep
here so I will just glue them back into
this so I take this one here and all the
pieces here that were missing and I
think this thing all the pieces have
been missing I just glue them back at
the corresponding note so this was a
child of R so I made them here a child
of r
okay and this is my new tree and we can
show that this is a login to the four
stretch
tree yes
translate any kind of band on the worst
case
[Music]
um yes no no no we are amortized I know
yeah this one could probably do work and
do this rebuilding in the background if
you have things in the background
yes yes yes we might be able to so
questions can be turned this into a
worst case algorithmic probably one foot
by doing some smart rebuilding in the
background they did not look into that
direction yeah
so the point is we can show that this
has now straight to log into the force
because the first thing head stretch log
into the third and then we get one more
probabilistic tree embedding on top
losing another login Factor
and the running time is basically the
update time for TD and for I and then
building this tree
um and running the probabilistic tree
embedding on it which is just linear M
poly log M log n so we get this running
time and then we need to amortize the
rebuild operation uh over square root
and many operations so all together we
end up with square root M Times log and
running time
okay so this was the first thing here
that I claimed
the stretch which is update time
now if instead of actually here instead
of here recomputing this from scratch If
instead keep a fully Dynamic algorithm
that stores P Union I
between any two rebuilds so we
recursively use our algorithm that we
just built and plug it into here what
you get is something that increases the
script stretch by another login Factor
but improves the running time
okay so you can keep because now this is
no longer linear this is just square
root okay so you can keep on applying
this recursively and that's where you
end up with this into the little fun
stretch and update time into the middle
of one
and my feeling is that something better
should be doable this is nice it works
but something better should be doable
and there are applications for example
you get faster Dynamic approximate oil
pressure orders path algorithm out of
this or a faster Dynamic biot file
Network design algorithm
okay but we have a few minutes left and
I want to tell you about experimental
evaluation of dynamic graph algorithms
so I want to step out of the theory
bubble for a second and tell you
something new here now you might wonder
why do I need to hear this
here is what is what shook me up okay so
uh Dynamic Delta plus one vertex
coloring where Delta is the maximum
degree so you want to give a color to
every vertex you have data plus one
colors available if two notes are
incident to each other they need to have
a different color
turns out there are two algorithms where
they're sort of competing
um one by batakaria grandori kulkani and
you and one by myself and ping
um this is panping not Richard ping and
now the question was which one would
actually perform better in practice
okay so I had this very good algorithm
engineering PhD student and I said can
you implement this tool
I want to know my bet was that my
algorithm would be better in practice I
was a smooth people in practice okay
which was true by the way but but this
guy was a very good Anderson's engineer
so he implemented this stuff but you
know just for sanity check he also
implemented another algorithm
which was not at all a constant time
okay he may implemented this time
um maintain a neighborhood color
histogram for every vertex so for every
vertex you know the color distribution
of the neighbors and then when you need
to recolor a note because an H was
inserted between two nodes of the same
color
pick a random color that is not used by
any neighbor and if you change your
color you need to tell all your
neighbors they could cause time data
because they need to update their color
histogram so this is all the data tab
but then you said ah maintaining data
structures is always bad let's just not
maintain the neighborhood color
histogram let's just run this algorithm
when recoloring just pick a random color
and then look at all your neighbors and
if there are some neighbors that have
the same color that you just chose then
you recolor them recursively
now you can argue it's also some kind of
Auto Delta running time
and then I said now let's look at the
experiments
and so the experiments were such that
this last one the orange one was best
then was the red one it's here then the
green one I was right with this one and
then the blue one
okay so these algorithms said that not
at all constant time blew us away
okay and we tried this this was on
random graphs we tried it on other real
world crafts it was always the same we
could build graphs that were
deliberately bad for the orange one then
the on such graphs the orange one was
then slightly worse than the blue one
but the red one was still better well we
came up with an algorithm that was
really bad for the red one then the
orange one was better there was just no
way that we could come up with a graph
that would beat both of them
so what do I learn from this or viruses
well of course updating these extra data
structures so these things here had lots
of extra data structure and this one
also still has the color histogram leads
to additional work and low locality of
memory access you were jumping around in
the data structure
at the y-axis is it running time is it
natural
yeah so I I wonder and this is 100 and
this is a 100 squared okay if you
measured it by some notion of Elementary
operations so as to disregard cash
performance
do you think you'd see uh substantively
better yes yes I want to so the question
is if you would count the number of
Elementary operations and not count cash
and not have running time but instead
this Elementary operations so you
disregard the cash effects yes then I
will take different results
because this is a local problem okay
that's what I'm saying down here so a
local problem where you can find your
answer by just looking at your
neighborhood and
if your cash is big enough then getting
your if you look at one neighbor it
costs you just as much as looking at all
your neighbors because you get the whole
neighborhood into your cash or maybe
into two cash lines right so basically
looking at one looking at the whole
neighborhood just cost you a profit
constantly and that's what these
algorithms here heavily exploit and our
rain model completely ignores that so
for us it's super expensive to look at
all the neighbors right it's Delta
so what do I learn from this first of
all I think it's very valuable to
implement and experimentally evaluate
Dynamic graph algorithms it sort of is a
sanity check for the work that we do and
maybe you know what you're optimizing
for is doesn't always make sense
and the other thing is there is of
course a model it's called external
memory model yeah that takes cash
effects into account and that has
actually very little on Dynamic graph
algorithms in the external memory model
I found only one paper here on the
incremental or decremental breadth first
search
so that might be a valuable area to look
into
um
in our survey actually we talked a lot
about what kind of uh graph algorithms
have been experimentally evaluated we
classified them into three types the
ones with a theoretically based
algorithm has been evaluated maybe
modified the ones where they are only
heuristics implemented and the ones
where their server knows only Theory and
no experimental evaluation needed
and now there are other advantages to
doing uh experimental evaluation one is
it's very easy to compare the
performance in different classes of
graphs right for example Sparks graphs
or power law graphs and so on and so
forth okay something where in theory you
know it takes up a lot of time to think
about does it perform better on this
class of graphs here you just run it and
see whether you get some improvements
it's also relatively easy to implement
different types of updates like rate
changes or vertex updates
and finally it's usually quite
convincing for engineers in the industry
once you have an algorithm that's
experimentally evaluated and this is a
way for us and our Theory Book they
actually have impact on real on the real
world
so that's my motivation when I look at
this
um it's actually not easy experimental
book especially good experimental work
one question is always where do you get
up-to-date data relevant data
and people use either real world graphs
or synthetic graph generated data what
are the right experiments and
measurements that's also not always so
clear so for example if you compare
yourself with a static algorithm you
might look at what is the break-even
problem size which is what is the
problem size such and when the graph is
this size or larger the dynamic
algorithm is actually faster than the
static one usually in small graphs
static algorithms are much faster than
Dynamic ones
you might also look at the insertion
deletion percentage so maybe the
insertions are fast and the deletions
are slow and then you might want to
check how many insertions do I need that
it's worth to use an Dynamic algorithm
maybe I should just run the static one
in real world updates are usually
patched and then the question might be
if the batches get too big is it still
worth to run a dynamic algorithm if the
batteries are too big a static might
again be better so look at the speed up
versus batch size
and then finally what is the right
Hardware to use nowadays you have this
multi-core CPUs gpus and so when you
implement these algorithms you have to
think about what do you use
and this also leads to the question
maybe we should be looking more at
parallel or massively parallel Dynamic
graph algorithms
um so summary here is there are
different advantages and challenges to
theoretical work but for us to have
impact algorithms engineering is an
important step okay it's an important
contributor and we should have high
respect for doing for people who do good
work in this area
so my overall summary now finally I
think Dynamic algorithms are useful I
hope I convinced you of that many upper
bound results exist but not so many have
been experimentally evaluated
for lower bounds there's some new
exciting work in the cell prop model and
there's also work in average Case Model
and for algorithms with prediction
and for upper bounds I showed you one
concrete problem and the questions of
course can you improve upon that
and other work problems that I like are
the gaps I mentioned before for all pair
shoulders path and maximum cardinality
matching
and um what I also think we should more
and more work on their Dynamic
algorithms with additional properties I
mentioned already external memory or
parallel but might also look at small
space and there there might be useful
lower bounds that we can get from the
streaming literature already what can be
done here or also a differentially
private Dynamic graph algorithms
thank you very much
[Applause]
yes does this work yeah here we go
so is my one venture to experimental
stuff I noticed that
my adventure into experimental stuff I
noticed that for the very very large
graphs with billions of edges and stuff
the representation matters too right
they're not given in how I would have
expected them to be represented have you
is that an issue
have you noticed that as an issue and
should we be dealing with particular
representations
yeah there's no standard representation
that's that's correct and um so
basically there's no standard represent
so I had the impression from the person
I was working with is in databases that
there are some standard representations
but I wasn't aware of them what what if
what have you seen in that respect well
so what we have been using is uh this
um K hip framework that came out of
um
extensions of uh C plus plus graph
extensions for C plus plus so that was
that was what we usually built upon and
that representation but when you get
graphs they're often represented in some
way and you have to first transform them
into a suitable representation for your
algorithms so you can't transform it as
you need it somehow
like you have to transform the whole
graph before you can work on it that's
what we usually did yeah so usually also
you just get a static graph and then
what you have to do is to run this in
some way into Dynamic graph so the
question is for example do you do
sliding window or do you do H flips
random Edge flips so what do you do yeah
um sometimes you get like Wikipedia
graphs and you get different times
snapshots at in time and then you can
say okay they must have happened the
batch update in between and and then you
put them in some random order so yeah
obviously
all right
thank you I was thinking about the upper
lower bounds in the very beginning of
the talk and I was wondering to what to
start on I was wondering to what degree
are there like better sill probe upper
bounds for some of these problems and
therefore the difference of like cell
probe conditional lower bounds has to do
with like the information theoretic
complexity of the problem versus the
computation I'm not aware of any work in
Cell Pro Papa bounce yeah that's a good
question
yep
yep if you are interested in the number
of shortest paths between every pair of
nodes is there still an ocean of
probabilistic really embedding that we
can utilize let's say for the purpose of
approximating the between the centrality
of vertices wait what is the question
now you said at least three things
counting the number of shortest paths
and now between actually yeah so let's
just focus on a number of shorts if you
are interested in the number of shortest
path between every pair of nodes is
there still an option of probability
embedding that we can use to approximate
that
I'm not aware of probabilistically
embedding the counter number of shortest
class no
and I mean as I showed if the shortest
passes links five it's going to be hard
to maintain dynamically anyway exactly
of course
um yeah that's the other weakness of
these lower bounds very often it's only
for the exact number and not for the
approximate number
yeah so
many of these conditional lower bounds
only hold for the exact setting so you
just want to approximate the number of
uh shortest past our lower bonds don't
say anything but I'm not aware of any
probabilistic trim buildings that would
do that
you mentioned uh Dynamic data structures
are useful and you mentioned industry do
you have any uh War Stories or uh
reports of uh examples of
these data structures being used in
practice
just one or two examples to inspire us
perhaps
so no and I can just say in the early
days of uh this online traffic
navigation systems and they didn't use
interesting Dynamic data structures but
then there was this very good work by
Goldberg at all on this graph Highway
graphs or something they were called
that showed that could be updated
efficiently
and at least in some variants for some
companies they weren't implemented
but initially no definitely not but I
haven't worked in industry for a long
time so maybe I'm the wrong person to
ask
next week we will have people from
industry and you should ask a question
yes yes okay so first of all thank you
so much for your presentation and
regarding the
um the time constraints and the uh all
these big constraints at the algorithms
from this uh work that you've been doing
with the trees have you taken into
consideration these like memory caches
and these problems that the
implementation enough is uh codes these
algorithms actually on this in your time
so the question is whether we have done
basically external memory algorithms for
for all these problems yeah and no I
mean the only external memory algorithm
for that I'm aware of are the ones that
I mentioned here for insertions only
Integrations only regrets for search
okay and there's like some uh let's say
let's have a menu for that like for this
exploration for like the part yes if you
publish external memory Dynamic graph
algorithms you can publish that in the
standard Theory conferences because
everyone is aware that external memory
algorithms are actually very tough and
to get speed UPS there is very
interesting and actually very much look
at conditional lower bounds for them
yeah I know yeah that might also be that
they all that that might be the reason
that there hasn't been much progress
I want to still encourage people to
think about them because
um let's not stick too much with the
smart model there's one model yes we can
you know tune our favorite parameters
but if we want to have impact you know
think about what what keeps us from
having impact and one of them is you
know these kind of examples here right
um which show that our model is not
perfect
but you know I'm not claiming I'm the
only one who knows how to fix things but
this and the parallel setting and I
think are very relevant in order to have
more impact
is given us how much
you wanted to missionaries
thank you